we have this tweet from Nuance bro and
he says this is how you do it folks all
right so let me give you some backstory
these uh Media Matters types are digging
up old comments and videos from Matt
Walsh when he had like a radio show when
he was younger they're taking them out
of context and trying to smear and
defame Matt Walsh and it's just it's
stupid there was one video they shared
where it's Matt Walsh and his friend
joking about burning a book and being
and like being Nazis or whatever but it
was funny because they couldn't get the
lighters to work and they were like just
wait until rednecks figure out fire and
they're like trying to light a book on
fire it was funny so in response to the
smear campaign against Matt Walsh he
responded by saying this
so here's my official answer
for the record
um
kiss my ass
I do not apologize
in fact by All rights you sick freaks
should be the ones apologizing to me
for lying and defaming me and doing it
all because I'm trying to prevent you
from sexually mutilating children
you damned monsters
you're child abusing Psychopaths
I wouldn't apologize to you soulless
parasites if I had a gun to my head
dude instead I'd rather just tell you
all to piss off
I apologize for nothing I concede
nothing
I Will Never Surrender even a single
inch of ground to a pitchfork mob of
degenerate morons
you know the secret they never say out
loud is that nobody is truly canceled
unless they consent to it and they
willingly play their assigned roles
well I do not consent
and I'm not going to play the game
I'm not going anywhere
that was absolutely amazing and that's
how it's done
that's how you do it folk says Nuance
Pro and that is that's it right there I
don't like the name calling though
that that I like Matt a lot but calling
people like insults is just inflaming I
think it's just inflamming if he really
wants to lower tension I mean if he
wants to these are people who have
intentionally taken audio from him out
of context and then lied about him to
try and cause damage to his work when
he's trying to help kids when he said
that I'm trying to stop you from
mutilating children I get that because
he is but when he calls them like
gratuitously morons and things like that
I don't know it's just I can understand
not wanting to insult someone in a
general context of a political argument
but this is different these are people
who are acting outside the bounds of
moralian Ethics they are seeking to
manipulate and lie to people for
political power what would you be
calling about yeah what would you say
what would be your response uh so your
met loss you're remaking this video go I
would have taken one of them no no go
you're on I know I'm talking to I'd be
talking to an individual I would say
their name and directly talk to them as
if they were sitting in front of me
an organization published a video who do
you respond to the CEO okay there you go
okay so what did I say
um you're well I mean Mr Poopypants
first you gotta figure out who said it I
mean if it's what is it like who's the
organization I don't know the the
specifics but I would talk to an
individual that's a big part of it is
you name them you talk to them as if
they're there they listen and they hear
that and they're like okay he's actually
talking to me now I'm trying to
understand there was someone who uh came
to one of our events and lied
and uh a leftist smear Merchant and
light and so I politely responded on
Twitter with like hey this thing you're
saying didn't actually happen I hope we
can resolve this and they responded with
something like I hope a bird craps on
your face and so I went okay I guess I
was at an event a political event and
the person who who in founded this
organization was on stage and so I asked
hey you say that your organization is
engaged in truth-telling in fact
checking when I when one of your uh you
know reporters posted uh verifiably
false statements about me and I asked
for a correction politely they said they
wished a burger crap on my face and it
says whatever ignored me and walked off
then you gotta go to the to the
individual that said they want the crap
on your face I talk directly to them in
a video by name Ian that's how you do it
you confront people and they love the
drama the crowd this is why people like
what Matt Walsh did because the problem
we face in the culture war is that
whatever this faction is constantly
tries to be nice
would not be nice to the person I would
directly confront them but them an
individual that this is my point they
are burning down pregnancy centers
they're firebombing them and then lying
about what the pregnancy centers do they
are lying about Matt Walsh and for for
the longest time you get people like
with you know with all due respect when
we had
um
why am I forgetting Rick Santorum on the
show and he's like no no no we gotta
Billy by the rules play by the rules and
I'm like yo they're burning down
buildings and we're not even saying do
that we're saying the law enforcement
should be dealing with it but at the
very least we don't just say I'm so
sorry let's be nice to them we say these
are evil awful people who are burning
down buildings what they what they were
trying to do with Matt Walsh was accuse
him of of being a child abuser because
of out of context comments from from 15
years ago who is it is it just text
comments that were insulting he was on a
radio show and he said something about
he said something like throughout
history women got pregnant at much
younger ages and now in today's day and
age they're saying it's a mistake if
women do but that's only because we
decided that I don't know the full
context I just know that they're taking
these things out of context which is why
he said outright you are seek you are
lying to defame me and I will not
apologize to you for it so look we
constantly have people saying like hey
why don't we invite this person to come
on the show question how come none of
the prominent leftists will come on the
show and sit down and have a
conversation some will but they tend to
have smaller followings they're trying
to establish themselves but for the most
part they don't and then what happens
when we do have some of these people on
they smack the microphone and freak out
and get angry yeah I make videos to
those people directly with their name
and I look at the camera while I'm
talking to them and you can humiliate
them to their face via video and
everyone gets to watch it doesn't do
anything oh it does a lot I used to do
it in the I mean it's pretty aggro but
you can definitely Shake someone by
doing that so so you have people who
make videos and comment on that all day
and night Matt Walsh came out and said
he smacked him back he he he
made it personal
and people are happy that he did because
people are sick this is why people voted
for Trump because for the longest time
you get people again I appreciate Rick
said to him coming on but his attitude
of being very deferential and saying
we're the ones who are going to play by
the rules it's like okay if you're
playing a game Monopoly and the person
sitting across the table is literally
cheating in front of you and you're like
well you're cheating and they go and are
you gonna keep playing I guess we better
play by the rules okay they're not but
you sit there anyway it's it makes no
sense so this is where he's finally
saying this is the sentiment that people
have been feeling for a long time I
don't care anymore you don't matter to
me you people are awful you are sick
they they killed people in the Summer of
Love they burned down buildings they uh
what they're doing to kids it's just all
abhorrent and I'm actually I'm very very
happy today that when I see this stuff I
know that I don't have to fear them and
Matt Walsh doing this give providing
this statement saying I would not
apologize to you parasites if there was
a gun to my head showing how successful
that is that he can do that that we
don't have to bend the knee to a
psychopathic cult it is freeing that we
we're not trying to be mean we're trying
to be nice we're trying to we're trying
to solve problems and we're trying to
find a path forward and what do we get
instead bricks through the window lies
manipulations and a refusal to to have a
con conversation
they stop Ben Shapiro from going to
events and speaking they stop Ann
Coulter from doing it they they spray
painted a death threat to liberals when
milianopolis tried to speak at an event
where where are the conservatives
burning down universities not happening
so at a certain point there is a group
of people saying you know what we don't
want what they're doing we don't want
violence we don't want retaliation but
you don't matter to us anymore at all
uh I don't know that Matt definitely
seems concerned if they didn't matter to
him he wouldn't have responded so Matt
doesn't talk about this very often but I
am sure that his entire family all six
of his children two of them unborn and
his poor wife are undoubtedly under
constant threat from these absolute
soulless monsters these are people who
will stop at nothing they will come to
your house it will break your windows
they will insult you if you go to try to
defend yourself they will get you
arrested they will call the cops on you
they will use the State against you they
arrested something like 11 old pro-life
protesters just for the crime of being
at a pro-life protest they will use
everything in the books their game is
power they talk about it all the time
because it's what they're going for and
they accuse the right of wanting it
because it's what they want more than
anything else and when they have power
they will not give you anything back
they don't care about your freedom of
speech and all he did was insult them
right there was a riot on January 20th
2017 where I mean you were there right
Luke we were both yes right I got I got
I got arrested you got away yeah I I
there's a huge line of Riot cops I
pushed right through them and got pepper
sprayed right in the face they were
forming a line and so I pulled I flanked
left to try and get away out of the
Riders Luke went forward and then the
cops boxed in the left area and then all
the Riders surrounded me but I I ended
up getting getting out because I had a
press credential these people
not only did they have the charges
dropped after they were smashing windows
and setting fire to Vehicles they
destroyed the the livelihood of an
immigrant who had leased a limo to do it
to be it to be a to run a company as a
driver they set his limo on fire
the cops that were unable to do anything
about it these people got arrested
and then after they were released and
the charges were dropped they filed a
lawsuit against the city and won and the
city paid them money and that's what
we've been dealing with for what a
decade now so for the longest time you
don't see there is a zero percent
probability that Matt Walsh's followers
storm a university to shut down these
speakers and that's actually really
funny because Matt says I'm trying to
stop you from harming kids and they
won't even protest you know to a certain
degree
obviously there are people that are
going out and protesting what I'm saying
is on the scale to the left is engaged
in this level of violence the right goes
nowhere near and and all we're getting
is Matt Walsh being like you are sick
degenerates and you're saying like oh
that's bad he shouldn't do that okay
well I can certainly understand why
you'd feel that way but you should
understand why people are like they burn
down a building and we've insulted them
and you're meditative if you want to
disperse a mob you got to shake one
individual up psychologically in yelling
expletives that the crowd doesn't fix
the problem which is the mob is insane
this is the point you take one of them
you make an example out of them by
insult by basically humiliating them in
front of the crowd and the crowd's like
oh I don't want to be Associated when
they refuse to come on these shows and
have no no if you make an internet video
directly to them yeah but Ian you're
sort of saying like don't be mean but
then be mean I'm not saying don't be
it's not just that it's like you're
saying scream into the wind no do you
make an internet you especially you
right now you make an internet video
talking to somebody watch the video you
don't know that if someone hears their
name on the Internet they're going to
that video
what they do and this is like the
perfect example is The Young Turks
instead of actually watching the segment
or maybe they do they just watch a clip
from some propaganda Channel and or at
the very least they watch it and then
lie about it like every single time The
Young Turks has done a segment about
something I've said they've lied about
what the context of the conversation was
for example we had a conversation
recently where I said something the
effect of I'm sure most women are happy
to have careers and engage in work I'm
sure some of them however probably end
up regretting it wishing they had
families and what they did was they took
that Twisted it and claimed I thought I
was saying something like women just
want to be wives and have babies which
is not what I said didn't change coach
you one time screaming at me and yeah
what was the lunacy
nuts they made a they made a smear piece
about Dave Rubin and they put my name
front and center for some reason and I
saw a Jank at political I was like hey
man how's it going I just I was trying
to get in touch with you I've been
messaging you you didn't respond but you
guys put up a video that like it was
about Dave Rubin or something but my
name was on it so I was just hoping I
could ask you like just in the future
how to do that and then he just started
screaming you're a trump supporter and
this was in like 2017 or something just
started screaming at me I don't remember
what he was saying at the time and I was
like why are you yelling at me and then
a bunch of journalists random start
filming and they're like what happened
I'm like I have no idea I was like dude
when nuts are screaming at me
these people have lost their minds dude
I have known Jank for a long time I
remember seeing him at VidCon and being
like hey I was gonna shaking his head
I've been in a show a couple times and
then one day I go to him and I'm like
hey you guys did like they were making
fun of Dave Rubin or something and they
used a report that had Tim Poole in
their thumbnail like right in the middle
and I I messaged Jacob I was like hey
man I was like you made a video and it's
got my name on it but it's about Dave
Rubin I'm just you know he ignored me I
messaged Anna who I also have known for
a long time and they ignored me and then
now they just make weird smear pieces
like there's no point in trying to have
a conversation with people who will
never come and have a conversation well
I think it's there's a point in trying
and eventually you know you can get
through it just because you guys are
talking like right now what's happening
is you're talking past each other you
talk about them they talk about you
message them I'm talking about internet
video communicate there used to be video
responses on YouTube the whole point was
you make a video to someone then they
answer you back and talk to you there's
communication people get to listen and
watch and then they start to mimic the
behavior yeah why do you think YouTube
removed videos Google bought it and they
don't understand social networking
well that's how they when I first met I
did a video response to Ian that was
that's how we first met look man
you know knowing these people for like a
decade and then one day Ian screaming in
my face in public and my response to
that is still consistently to politely
invite him for a conversation you said
Ian chank chank sorry sorry I wouldn't
do that to you baby that means you're
like far away I need you to hear me I'll
be in five years knowing knowing this
guy for as long as I have having polite
conversations appearing on a show on
more than one occasion then one day
abruptly and for no reason he starts
screaming in my face in public I made a
video about him like I have no idea what
happened I have no idea why he's
screaming at me I'm not Alex Jones I
don't have any beef with them I've never
argued with them before I've never had a
negative word about him he just started
screaming at me in public cameras
everywhere they're filming it and I'm
like what's happening I was like why are
you yelling at me and then even after
that I still politely say we'd love to
have you on the show at any time we'll
cover all costs I know that's a great
position but he they never they will
never do it never because they are not
genuine people this is why when Matt
Walsh says you are degenerate morons
people are cheering for it because for
too long we have tried to politely just
be like can we please talk and resolve
this and they say no we're going to burn
your city down we're gonna beat your
elderly we're going to try and kill Kyle
Rittenhouse you're talking about a lot
of different people though I'm talking
about all of these people aligned with
this movement this cult this ideology
for whatever reason and and there's
various subcultures within it but for
some reason all of them refuse to have a
conversation a small handful will have a
conversation Jimmy Dore who's basically
an outright socialist is called far
right it's it's nonsensical cult
meaninglessness I wonder if he's changed
because he actually spat in Alex's face
on one yeah and then they were there
Young Turks were doing this sit down at
was it the RNC right RNC in Cleveland
and and Alex came up laughing and
talking to them while they were doing
their thing and they got mad Jimmy spit
on Alex we were standing right there it
was crazy they're like what the hell's
going on here so look I can understand
but now Jimmy actually supports Free
Speech which is great well he's always
supported free stuff yeah but like then
having a seems like obscene Behavior
sure sure look I I think what Jimmy did
in that context was was wrong but I
think there's a difference between
someone coming and interrupting your
live shot so you're having a personal
beef with them and whether or not you
support free speech like I don't think
it's inherently free speech that someone
walks up to you during your show and
starts trying to interrupt it you know
what I mean that's that's a different
question but but sure Jimmy should not
have got baited in spam or whatever I I
think Jimmy has consistently called out
the establishment the Democrats and what
he encounters is all of a sudden people
are blindly marching in lockstep behind
them and he's like since when since when
have we supported this machine this
corporate Democrat machine and they're
like your right wing he's like what I
did see a segment of Anna and chank you
know pushing back against the defund the
police so it's not all one group no no
you know this is funny though you're
right they recently and I gave him
credit for it yeah came out saying
defund the place is stupid but you know
they very heavily supported it
so yeah they were tweet I saw a certain
things right a bunch of tweets came out
and so people were like they supported
this now look change your mind exactly
and that's why I'm like that good on
them but the issue is it's it's
politically expedient defund the police
has become unpopular they are following
the polls that's it
if anything I have all the reason in the
world to just keep doubling down and
being like Trump's the best Trump's the
best instead I'm like I don't know man I
think Ron DeSantis maybe and then why is
he saying why is Trump saying death
penalty for drug dealers right that is
insane why like just don't so this but
we can break this down first yeah I
don't I disagree with the death penalty
outright second however
most people interpret that as
specifically having to do with
traffickers of like heroin and opioids
and things like that or if you're lacing
stuff with Fenton right right not like
someone's slinging pot and the other
argument is that when it comes to those
things these people have killed dozens
hundreds or more so but be specific like
don't make statements like that you have
to be targeted in your language no and
that's Trump yeah that's just right so I
I that's why you know when I look at uh
there's there's some tweets right now
someone tweeted at me Will Chamberlain
it was it was an amazing show we had
here with a handful of people and you
know Will Chamberlain said something
like he actually thinks the FED is good
and then everyone else goes like ah no
like it's like the most shockingly
offensive thing you can say to anybody
in this room but Will's great we love
having well in the show even though we
completely disagree on that and then we
have uh ilad aliyahu who reports for it
for timcast and he's talking about how
he supports military intervention
because he wants a monopolar world with
the US charge and we got really into it
I was yelling I had to apologize and uh
but we think he's fantastic we com we
disagree to the point where we were like
really angry and I was like this is I
was pissed
um but I think he's I think he does an
amazing job and I think you know we're
glad to have those conversations
but there's that group of people that
claim to be the left they will not come
on they will not talk and for some
reason their opinions flow with the wind
as however the polls are suggesting it's
amazing in whatever is the popular group
think I mean we even disagree we have
debates on this show and and iron
sharpens iron it's great to have those
conversations it's great to challenge
yourself it's great to actually question
things instead of just like hey this is
what people want me to say I'm just
going to say it because I want to be
liked and that's where a lot of these
people come from this is kind of group
heard sheep mentality and this is why
you never bend the knee to the the
Pitchfork mob this is why you never
acquiesce to everyone in the status quo
is going along with because if you're
doing that you're just degressing
yourself when we should be challenging
ourselves we should be questioning
ourselves we should be of course always
going up to Authority and saying not
today you SOB because you deserve some
accountability some transparency and you
deserve to be questioned outright with
what you're doing with the power that
you have power should always be
challenged these people are just trying
to get as much as they can for
themselves and and truly screwing
everyone and giving a disservice not
only to Their audience but also to
themselves by doing this so question
everything and and this is why I like I
I liked what I saw with Matt Walsh
because it's come it comes from that
energy like I'm not going to do what you
tell me to do I'm not going to say two
plus two equals five and this is why a
lot of people seeing this from from Matt
Walsh today I don't agree with
everything that Matt has to say or think
but when he came out with this message
it was a resounding Fu to anyone in the
establishment anyone trying to control
him and and that's something that I want
to see more of I think the never
apologize idea is generally true
assuming like never apologize you know
for uh your principles never go back
against your principles but the idea of
never apologizing is a blank statement
makes no sense like you should apologize
when you want to apologize and your core
principles tell you that that's the
appropriate thing to do I loved when he
was just like by all accounts you should
be apologizing to me yeah so he
acknowledges that apologies are needed
sometimes yeah yeah that was good yeah
you know what man
I think I think he hit a home run and
and the more the point is you have
people who go on Twitter who lie trying
to get people fired from their jobs this
was one of those circumstances I a lot
of people have you know come out and
been like I'm so sorry you're angry with
me and they still lose their jobs Matt
Walsh hey look the daily wire is not
going to fire Matt Walsh over this
they're going to be laughing about it
and he gets the opportunity to come out
and say this by doing so it is a stake
in the heart of the cancel culture mob
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there